- One of your biggest hits was,
"I Will Always Love You."
You did write that.
Do you remember the first time
you heard Whitney's version?
- Yes.
- [Kelly] 'Cause I grew up hearing yours,
and then all of a sudden,
"The Bodyguard" happened.
I'm just curious, what was your first,
cause it's your baby.
- Well,
there's a li'l story about that.
When they were doing
"The Bodyguard" movie,
they had chosen another
song for the theme song,
and someone came out with that very song
right when they were about
to put the movie out.
And they were drastic to, I mean,
they were really trying
to find a great song,
and Kevin Costner and his secretary,
they said, "Do you remember
Dolly Parton's song
of, "I Will Always Love You?"
It's a country song, but
it's a beautiful song."
And so, they called me
to see if they could use it
and I said, "Yes."
And I didn't hear anything else about it.
I didn't know if they had it.
I didn't know if they had done it.
And I was driving my car
from downtown where my
office was, on 16th Avenue,
back to my house over in Brentwood,
and I was just driving along
and I had the radio on,
and I just heard this,
♪ If I ♪
♪ Should stay ♪
You know the
- Yeah.
- It's one of those things,
it's like a dog hearing a whistle.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(audience laughs)
- I go, what is that?
And all of a sudden.
- That's the first time?
- And that's the first time.
They hadn't sent it to
me, they did nothing.
I heard it on the radio.
And so, when it went into,
♪ And I ♪
- Yeah.
- And it's like I just freaked out.
I had to pull over to the side
because I honestly
thought I was gonna wreck.
It was the most overwhelming feeling.
And you know how great that was.
- Oh my God.
- And it was great.
But, that's the story of that.
But when you sang that,
when we did the Academy
of Country Music Awards,
when you did that at the end,
I mean to tell you that whole crowd,
Whitney, she would've been so proud of you
'cause I felt like she was watching you.
(audience claps)
(Kelly gasps)
You absolutely killed it.
Seriously. It was incredible.
And I was so emotional.
- [Kelly] Me too. Right now.
It hit me that you're
talking about me singing.
It's fine.
- Well,
it was great though.
- No.
- It was incredible.
- I will cry.
We're not.
They're saying, "Can you do a little?"
No, I will cry.
- [Audience] Please.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] No.
- [Audience] Please.
(audience cheering)
- How about if I sing a little bit of it
and you sing harmony with me?
- Okay. Okay.
- Okay, I'll sing a li'l, okay.
(Kelly inhales)
- Whoo, I'm not crying.
- ♪ And I ♪
- ♪ I ♪
♪ Will always ♪
♪ Love you, I ♪
♪ Love you ♪
- ♪ You ♪
- [Kelly] That break
(audience clapping)
that you made.
(audience cheering)
- It's the little things.
(Dolly laughs)
(audience cheering)
It's the little things.
I don't know if y'all heard,
it was like on "will" that there's this,
your breaks and your voice are so magical.
You're like a magical fairy human,
I don't know.